hey youtubers is Charlie there's a
really big story going around about
Channing Tatum's gambit movie maybe
falling apart so I thought this would be
a really important video to do just in
case anyone doesn't know what's going on
with the movie this is gonna be a big
update I'll also have a couple
recommendations for really good gambit
stories to read at the end of this so
the big story that's going on right now
is that Channing Tatum is ready to walk
from the gambit movie now currently he's
on as a producer so like like he's very
involved in the actual making of the
film he's not just an actor in it it's
kind of like the relationship that Hugh
Jackman has with the Wolverine
standalone films he's very involved in
the story in the making of the actual
films he doesn't just like walk up to
set and put his claws on did like the
day before they start filming there are
a lot of people that are saying the
channing tatum has left the movie that's
not true he's just ready to walk and
most people feel like he let this story
get out on purpose so that the media
would cover it and it would be a way to
strong-arm Fox apparently the deal to
make the movie is what's falling apart
behind the scenes and it probably has
something to do with Channing Tatum
wanting more money than Fox wants to pay
to make the movie like he wants to make
you know big 150 million dollar movie
just like x-men days of future past and
x-men apocalypse but maybe Fox feels
like it should be a smaller movie that
would be one of the few things that
could bring everything to a grinding
halt because Channing Tatum is really
excited about the gambit character he
went to comic-con to promote the film
even though they haven't even started
shooting yet they're supposed to start
in a couple weeks which is why this is a
really big deal that talks are breaking
down it's a really strange turn of
events where an actor this big signs on
to produce and star in a major franchise
I mean it's part of the x-men universe
and then things fall apart like a week
or two before they start filming
they've already been auditioning
actresses for the female lead I mean
they have a pretty good handle on what's
going on with the film so that's why
everyone seems to think that it's all
about budget if you remember it was
actually like last time this year route
you around like comic-con I think maybe
a little bit before Comic Con the
Channing Tatum expressed an interest in
doing a gambit movie it was really in
the wake of x-men Days of Future past
like that that movie was so successful
all of Hollywood wanted to be a part of
it any time like a big movie blows up
people always like hey I want to be in a
comic book movie like even Al Pacino
wants to be part of a Marvel movie now
that they have all these older actors
like Michael Douglas so let's like the
worst case scenario for a game but right
now
well talks you know don't resolve in
time for them to start shooting on time
so they have to push the movie to like
20 17 ideally if they could get things
rolling now then they could still get
the movie out sometime in 2016 but I
mean if this spills into like December
and they don't start shooting till next
year then it's gonna take another year
to get the film out it's crazy how fast
they can turn big movies like that over
especially when they have a lot of
pre-existing infrastructure from films
like x-men apocalypse it's always easier
from a production standpoint to make
like the next film and a franchise than
it is to do it the first time there
isn't a whole lot we know about the
story of this gambit film you know other
than since it's gonna be his first big
film and he hasn't been in the x-men
films for a long time it's probably
gonna tell a version of the origin story
even if it doesn't spend most of the
film doing that I think Fox and everyone
learned a lot of lessons from Wolverine
Origins and you know just in terms of
how much time you spend developing the
character in how much of that first film
he spends being the superhero is like
how long do you want people sitting in
that movie theater to wait before they
get to see the gambit that they know and
love definitely within the first half
hour of that movie and just remind her
when they went in to pitch the film this
was pitched is its own separate thing
they didn't originally pitch it as being
part of the x-men universe so I mean I
mean yes
Fox probably wants it to crossover like
they want that synergy that Marvel has
but the character has to work on his own
first so I'm gonna guess the Channing
Tatum's
current gambit film you know unless they
change the script is very x-men light
you know like loose allusions to the
rest of the x-men existing in the
universe but for the most part it's just
going to be his character in the people
central to his origin story and they
haven't been super clear on you know
which era the film is gonna take place
in like how old is gambit
whenever say like things in Days of
Future past whenever those events are
going on or when stuff in x-men
apocalypse is happening my guess is is
that he'll be about the same ages like
there as the rest of the x-men
just because Channing Tatum in real life
looks very close to their age gambit is
not immortal so you know therefore he
was born probably around the same time
that a lot of the other mutants were
born but within the same decade they're
really on
like a handful of mutants in the in the
x-men universe right now that we've seen
on screen that are way way older than
the other mutants apocalypse you know
being the extreme case but if all goes
to plan he will definitely crossover
with the x-men films at a certain point
but I mean they have to kind of work up
to that I know that sounds weird that
like a movie this big with an actor this
big you know with a fandom that's like
so ready for x-men apocalypse is having
problems but when you're spending a
hundred fifty million dollars to make
something even the slightest wrong turn
could throw things off the rails so even
if everything ends up going to and
Channing Tatum leaves the project
they'll still be gambit at a certain
point but Fox's contingency plan might
be to just roll him into the x-men films
with a lesser actor if Channing Tatum
doesn't work out here's my big question
for you guys like would you rather Fox
just like wait and work things out with
Channing Tatum if it's gonna take like
two years for them to get things under
control and we don't see gambit for like
three or four years or would you rather
them just like cut their losses and pick
a smaller actor and roll him into the
x-men apocalypse franchise we've gone so
long without gambit I feel like that
there's no problem and just like waiting
for Channing Tatum to work things out
with Fox I feel like that would be a
good film
Channing Tatum is an amazing performer
he's just he's trying to get like his
directing and producing career
jump-started so in another year or two
like you will see Channing Tatum
directing a movie a good example of like
Studios having problems with big actor
slash producers is Tom Cruise on the
mission impossible franchise way back
when Tom Cruise seemed like he was
acting really erratically jumping on the
couch and he had a lot of bad press the
studio tried to fire him from the
mission impossible franchise they were
unsuccessful and obviously he went on to
make two more Mission Impossible films
so they can work things out with that
then surely Channing Tatum and Fox can
come to an arrangement why he has late
for all this drama to die down here a
couple really awesome gambit stories
from the comics you need to read theirs
out of the frying pan into the fire this
is just a small two-part story it's the
one that introduced him to the Marvel
Universe it was Chris Claremont and Jim
Lee so this is like his very first story
ever he teams up with a teenage version
of storm he goes up against the villain
called the shadow king who's a telepath
that's so powerful that he doesn't need
physical body next up is the heart of
thieves this is actually a story setting
gambits passed when he was still in
Paris
working for the Thieves Guild game is
just like one of those characters that
has like a really trouble past just like
Wolverine but doesn't quite have the
hero art that Wolverine got gambit is
still something of a great character
Wolverine you could consider chaotic
good gambit I would say is more true
neutral but he goes up against
Sabretooth Sabretooth is like the big
villain to this storyline then there's
honor amongst thieves this is actually
like the for the first big miniseries
did he ever got he ends up having to go
back to his hometown in New Orleans and
and stop this war between the thieves
and the Assassin's Guild rogues a big
part of it so if you're a big fan of
like rogue and gambit storylines this is
a lot of fun it's kind of one of those
situations where we're like your new
girlfriend learns all about the awful
things in your past that you haven't
told her yet whenever you bring her home
to meet the family so it did a good job
of fleshing out a lot of gambits
backstory that hadn't been explored
before so those are just a couple
stories to get you guys started there I
mean there's plenty more gambit in the
Marvel Universe he became one of
apocalypse as horsemen for a little
while even though that storyline kind of
got dropped I was I was a little upset
about that because he looked badass as a
horseman if there's any other like
gambit or x-men related videos that you
guys want me to do just leave me
requests in the comments I'll try to do
some more x-men apocalypse next week
just because I mean there's a lot of
stuff going on behind the scenes with
that movie all good things though Bryant
Bryan Singer has just been posting a lot
of stuff on social media there were a
couple other videos I was working on
like before this stuff like literally
just happened so there'll be some
Walking Dead and flash tomorrow I've
also got a joker video that I'm trying
to finish so wait guys wait for all that
stuff to drop you can click here to
learn about Marvel's big Netflix plans
for the next couple of years they just
announced a whole bunch of Netflix stuff
for like all the the daredevil Jessica
Jones Marvel series The Punisher a lot
of stuff and you can click here for like
a big channel update on stuff that I'm
working on like stuff that's going on
later this year and the big stuff that
YouTube has been changing they change
the mobile app in like a couple other
things so thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you